what's up guys welcome to another
episode of get close i'm geo and i'm
bart
and um
the house has been feeling
so nice these days because my mom has
been staying with us just for a little
bit um you know just to switch things up
and um
i don't ever realize how much i miss her
and how cuny she makes the house feel
until she's like here i wish her mom was
my mom
why my mom [ __ ] sucks what do you
mean
like you know when you have a really
good mom
what sucks about your mom
she's like um
and you don't mean she like sucks you
just mean
you just wish you had my mom
which means she sucks
because most people love their moms
right
that's like a pretty like a pretty
generally like accurate statement yeah
yeah i love my mom yeah yeah yeah um you
love your mom i love her in our own way
but not i don't not in the universal way
all right do tell like you know like
when you when you first go to college
right and you meet people from other
walks of life other cities whatever
and then you just you know you're like
connecting and you're at the dorms or
whatever and you hear people like oh
yeah man i love my dad or i love my mom
and she's like this whatever like i
always felt like a certain feeling that
they had like
like they they're talking about a best
friend
that always has their back
and is always kind of like their own
personal bank and is like their role dog
like that
feeling of like
uh if [ __ ] hits the fan i can always go
back to my mom and it just feels like
this warm embrace like this
even i even see it in the animal kingdom
you know like you see like a baby like
have you seen [ __ ] monkeys how they
[ __ ] treat their kids
it's [ __ ] funny
like the mom will be like quack quack
quack quack like push them and then
[ __ ] come here oh but then i also see
the [ __ ] i also see the baby monkey
on the mama monkey's back and the mama
monkey's climbing [ __ ] and then we'll
like like get like a bug and then feed
it directly to the back yeah
cute yeah i pictured it's white ass for
his hands yeah and then grab it and then
feed it backwards to the little i've
seen that and so even just that entire
motherly feeling that people go oh man
i need to go back even david right like
i talk to my mom every day his mom is
[ __ ] cuny she doesn't even speak
english but her eyes tell me more than
any words could ever ever say
like the first time i met her
um
she looked at me up and down and i can
already hear all the [ __ ] she was saying
but like it's cuny you know what i mean
she was probably going like look at this
[ __ ] tall [ __ ] [ __ ] you know yeah
but like i know it comes from such a
warm place because her eyes were smizing
i see and it looks like she's always
thinking some mischievous thoughts and
like um but they're just all filled with
love i see
yeah so i love her that feeling of
i love my mom
i don't think i've ever felt that
damn yeah but i feel with your own mom
your mom's [ __ ] dope so if you could
share your mom that's pretty [ __ ]
tight don't we share my mom
yeah but not like step siblings
give me more that's it that's it that's
it i think i'm going down a road that
has a lot of like edges jagged edges
that's going to crack
okay let's not go down that road yeah
because i hear like like uh when you go
to la you stay with her and i'm here in
vegas because taka has school and then
you're like yeah me and my mom i mean me
and your mom
imagine you start kicking me out yeah uh
you're like yeah me and your mom we were
talking for like hours and did you know
that this about your family i'm like no
i didn't
but i think it's so [ __ ] cool you
want to know what [ __ ] daily
comparison is it's like this
um this is a day in the life of like me
and your mommy and my mom
me and your mom i wake up good morning
oh hey ma morning hey hey would you like
uh something to eat you want like i can
make you a quick enchilada i can make
you a breakfast burrito or something
before you take off to work you know
that
if i wake my if i wake up with my mom i
wake up hey good morning
you didn't say mama good morning
better say mama good morning so it
starts off like that like you got to be
proper you got to address the person so
it has to be mama nita i can't just say
nita has to be like
well
we'll be like [ __ ] peasants we don't
know how to address people by their
official title
you know she's very like like you know
in those like but then yet she like
[ __ ] sits cross leg picking her
[ __ ] teeth
and then burps that's okay yeah i don't
know so it's confusing because she's
she's like
that motherly figure in those princess
movies like i am that's not the proper
way to do it you know while she's like
yeah so she's like um you didn't address
me by mother right she's like that and
then i go in the kitchen she goes would
you like some oh no she won't even ask
she's like drink this ginseng [ __ ]
goop [ __ ] you know so it's just a lot of
it is like with your mom i feel very
nurtured she wants to take care of me
um and it's a very like two-way like
type street
with my mom it's like a one-way [ __ ]
like that and then so like
i never feel the oh man i want to see my
mom on christmas i can't wait to go back
like for me it's like i can't wait to go
see someone else's mom for christmas
well you can always share my mom man
she's the [ __ ] best she's everyone's
mom
everyone [ __ ] loves my mom she's a
[ __ ] she's so thoughtful
um she's so nurturing and i love seeing
the interaction with her in taika right
now cause like they just play so much
and it makes me happy because like at
her age
um i love that she's tapping into such a
imaginative world
she's like i hear her her and and the
monkey dude and they're like
the monkey kid's like
hey give me all your money she's like no
no please don't take my money please
right and they're like playing and then
i'll walk in and then he's like mom do
you want to play and i'm like yeah so
then i'm playing and my mom's like oh
watch out for that one he's like the
stuffed animal she's like that guy he's
gonna be good to you but then he's gonna
turn his back on you he's gonna stab you
in the heart or something like that and
i'm like what the [ __ ] it's so cute like
they have their own little world
um and i like
that like
i don't know i like whatever i wish i
had and maybe i did have it but i was
just too stupid to see it like whatever
i wish i had the parent i wish i had
it's so cuny that taika gets to
experience that because like we're
working or we're doing whatever like
grandma is
the [ __ ] softest pillowy cloud that
he can
do no wrong
like she still feeds she so [ __ ]
feeds him yeah but you didn't have that
right
[ __ ] no so you're so you're saying my
mom was working her ass off yeah so
you're saying you you like that he got
he got a part of your mom that you
didn't yes oh that's cute yeah yeah yeah
i love it i love to see it and i love
that like he's like so stuck on her um
but the more she's here the more i
realize how [ __ ] dumb i am and how
little i know about like
raising kids really like what like even
just things like medicine right like
she'll know
like this herb will do this type of
thing because she comes more from like
an old school you know like yeah yeah oh
if you have an earache then put um in
spanish it's called
but in english i think it's called mint
i think but show no specific plants or
specific remedies you know or like
certain things that are more like old
school where me i'm like i don't know
i'm just gonna go to [ __ ] cvs and
hope this kind of works you know but
like she just knows a lot of like
the new age things versus like the old
you know so she's like in in these in
between worlds
where i'm still like man it's wisdom i
think that's what i'm saying do you
think that's crushing us
what's crushing us like i feel like i
think it started with like autocorrect
right where you're using autocorrect and
then people don't know how to spell
anymore right and then you have
calculators people know how to do math
and i realize it's autocorrect for
everything right so
back in the day i think was pretty
common maybe even up to my generation
literally me and all my homies and
everyone older knows how to change a
flat tire knows how to change do a oil
change
but nowadays it's just oh aaa that's the
autocorrect
i'll call triple i don't need to know
anything right and so even with like
these herbal remedies
i think it's like like the chinese
version is probably like ginger and
honey or whatever you know that's like
that
but then now it's like the most basic
like ice pack this or do whatever that i
feel like we're slowly starting to lose
touch with that and i'm like like when i
see the way um
your mom takes care of taika
there's like so many things and i'm like
damn am i [ __ ] that dumb i don't know
how to do like half those things same
that's what i'm seeing too
um
is it messing us up i guess
right i guess yesterday was i was
playing with taika right and i
accidentally elbowed him in the head
and then he kind of had like a headache
and then for me i'm just like oh i guess
better sleep it off or whatever right
and then your mom i saw her get out of
her room to go get a ice pack i'm like
oh yeah that's something we did in
recess remember in recess like people
would like run run run into each other
the nurse would give him an ice pack i'm
like that's what ice packs are i don't
even remember [ __ ] like that i don't
know if it's messing us up
um but i think what is messing us up and
this is what i was trying to get to
is that like
we don't live in communities anymore
you know like um
like you can't know everything like i
can't know everything and that's why
it's so important to be around friends
of all walks of life or family um of all
age groups because they're all coming in
to it with their own specialties with
their own wisdom with their own
perspectives
um and i think that's that whole [ __ ]
it takes a village thing
you know because like my mom might be
really dumb compared to her mom right
like her mom might know a bunch of other
[ __ ] because she's been here longer she
knows like
you know what i'm saying like so you're
saying we're way more specialized and
our general knowledge is lower
um
what i'm saying is
for me only i feel like because i don't
live in a community anymore like i'm not
part of a community we're out here in
vegas by ourselves we don't really have
our friends we don't really have our
siblings or my siblings um i don't have
my family members like you know like so
like when i see just just a smaller
example is when i see like my
sister-in-law taking care of her kids
that are exact same age as tyka i'm like
oh [ __ ] right
oh [ __ ] you can do it that way or or
they're still drinking milk this way or
like i'll i'll ask her for questions
like hey when did they get potty trained
oh that so then i kind of follow suit
because i'm like oh that's the standard
i see whereas like right now i'm
figuring a bunch of this [ __ ] out on my
own and yeah there's the internet and
stuff but like
when it comes to the internet
um and like the people on it now you
have to make a relationship with the
people that you follow or you have to
have a relationship to now go like oh i
do trust what they're saying and they're
not trying to sell me it's not like the
misinformation or whatever and it's
colder when you learn things on the
internet it's almost the difference
between like like mom's peach cobbler
recipe and then this peach cobbler
recipe it's like this one it's pretty
good but the mom knows the little the
little symbols the little zaza little
you know and i think yeah my mom knows
all those i think even with like um
kids raising kids it's it's like that
too it's like on here you can read like
a mom's blog i changed the diapers when
she's never bad yeah but then now i now
like when i read that right like i don't
i can't connect to it because i'm like
but who are you as a person like are you
like a [ __ ] foofy person so you're
only going for name brand stuff yeah you
yeah so i'm like i'm not gonna listen to
you but like if it's my family and
people i already have a relationship
with i'm way more open especially if i
respect them way more open to take in
whatever they're doing because i'm like
you're doing it right i want to do it
that way yeah um but having her here now
i'm going [ __ ]
i really want to build like my community
up again out here
but then
because i see all the benefits but then
i'm going but [ __ ] man i gotta talk to
people
you hate people so much huh i don't hate
people it's just people give me so much
anxiety
it's so drainy but that's what you have
to do if you want community no [ __ ] i
just said that dude so which one is it
gonna be what's gonna be i think it's
just gonna be by myself
okay so [ __ ] the community now honestly
honestly um i think i'm just gonna have
to build the community oh so it's cool
that like joe's out here now and anytime
that like we do something and i know
that they're in town i'm like hey hit up
joe or like i hit him up on my own you
know like hey joe we're gonna go do this
you want to come through and usually he
says yes yeah so we have that such an
awesome uncle he's [ __ ] rad man like
he's he's the perfect blend of friend
uncle
frunkel he's a frunkle because he's not
like trying to educate him all the time
but he's definitely very much aware of
like what's kid appropriate things so
there's been multiple times when like ty
is watching some [ __ ] and he'll
immediately be like hey you can't be
watching that and then he'll give that
to me he's like hey he's watching this
[ __ ] and i'm like oh damn he's like no
we're we're actually okay with him yeah
yeah blade's good weight's fine blade
300 oh that's actually fine give it back
especially blade 2 with the [ __ ] what
are they called well he calls it the
weepers what are these they're actually
called reapers oh it's that new creature
that eats vampires so it's even crazier
you can't watch it i like that they
one-upped it like that because you
thought vampires were the top of the
food chain nope the weepers are the
weepers i know and he knows so much and
he's telling me like all these story
lines and i'm like bro i can't watch
that that's just [ __ ] scary he's like
mom what do you mean it's scary it's
just make-believe because i really want
to put it in his head that movies are
fake yeah and i'm like yes dude i know
but i can't get over what the [ __ ] i
taught to try to teach you okay he might
be a jordan peel
that'd be tight because you know like
jordan feels like super comedy but then
all his movies are [ __ ] crazy yeah
what if that's tyka's brain where he's
like i would i [ __ ] hope he's still
goofy but he loves that crazy horror
[ __ ] i love it i can't wait i can't wait
to [ __ ] further nurture that yeah i
hope he's like a [ __ ] goofy creepy
dude speaking of like those crazy um
like mom remedy type stuff your mom did
something the other day that blew my
mind i'm like holy [ __ ] that's crazy so
you know how like tycho's about to go to
sleep
and uh but he's been running around uh
outside with me as i was grilling right
so the bottoms of his feet were [ __ ]
dirty so your mom's like i'm gonna have
to wash your feet before you go to bed
right his body's clean because he took a
shower so he's gonna like redo the whole
shower
and then wake him up yeah and his attack
was like oh okay cool whatever and then
um so i thought she was gonna take him
to the shower but while tycho was
hanging out with us your mom just got
two three squirts of lotion put it on
the bottoms of his feet and just took
the t-shirt and wiped it off and his
feet was clean oh
my god dude those are those [ __ ] [ __ ]
cuz that was our [ __ ] like little
tips yeah that you can't really learn
online yeah cause you know everything
online is right this is how i did it
when it's all so circumstantial right
like you need to be in that
like
that specific
like moment for that to make sense and
like you can't really teach that yeah
yeah but those are the things that i
like i feel like that's the difference
between the mama recipe and what you
learn you know like you don't learn like
the real like
authentic tricks of the trade type [ __ ]
from internet because everything's so
cold yeah reading where like when i saw
that i was like oh wow well there's just
too much explanation right can you
imagine a blogger trying to explain to
you
that specific moment and to go that
versus water and like the thought
process and then going but you don't
always want to do this this is only
going to be when like he's half asleep
like it's such a specific thing and
that's what i mean by like the community
part
and now a word from our sponsor
betterhelp
how well would you take care of your car
if you had to keep the same one your
entire life
damn i love that question that's how our
brains work so why wouldn't we treat
them that way i love that because we all
know after certain
miles we need an oil check or we need to
lift up the hood and see what's going on
in there i wish that our like bodies
would be like you know our hand would
like change a color i mean i guess it
does right
when it needs some help but i wish our
brains had like like a little icon or
something that goes like hey let's check
it out
but it doesn't but we should be viewing
it that way so how we care for our minds
affects how we experience life and that
is a hundred percent true so it's
important to invest time and care into
keeping them healthy and i couldn't
agree with that statement more like
it's been in
ingrained in us that every year we need
to get a physical exam right just to
make sure that everything is oiled up
and properly working and you know we we
add more
years to our life than subtract from
them
and i as far back as i can remember
that's always something that's been like
really instilled in us but why not our
brain whereas we know through study and
studies and science and experiments that
our brains can really affect the health
of our body right
you know it can really affect how like
the statement says how we view life
so
when i heard that better help
exists it made me so happy to know that
we have so much access to licensed
therapists at our fingertips because
some of us live in areas where we don't
have you know the access to the
the caliber of therapists that we need
some of us might live in a rural rural
area where we can't just get in our cars
and leave or we might just be you know
in a place where we don't have the right
support so it's really dope that better
help exists because better help is an
online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat only therapy
sessions so um you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't feel
comfortable doing that
it's much more than affordable it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
you can be matched with the therapist in
under 48 hours okay and for everyone
listening right now we are hooking you
guys up with 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
get close that's better help h e l p
dot com slash get close
i'm like i love observing
people that are doing things the way i
would imagine them to be done and then
going oh
because you learn that too when you're
cooking like that's why i think a lot of
people like watching
um cooking shows because yeah obviously
they're telling you the recipe and who
can't follow a [ __ ] recipe right like
you have to be
pretty special to [ __ ] that up yeah but
like who can't follow the measurements i
think it's how they chop it up the
little way they toss it in and like just
the little like tidbits that they're
adding like their own personal touches
that you're just like oh
or how they're storing things or how
like they're like actually this is not
in the recipe but i realize that when
it's room temperature versus whatever
it's like easier you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah yeah so stuff like that
so like as she's here now i'm like
taking it all in dude i'm just like can
you just live with us please yeah when
your mom's in the kitchen i'm always in
there with her yeah i've i've learned so
much like when she makes her sopas she's
like this is one of my best kept secrets
and she'll she'll just get mayo and she
puts it on the sope first because it's
all fat and then she gets the beans and
then she's like no one knows this
and you just [ __ ] told everybody and
i was like i'm gonna tell her
and i was like why do you do that she
goes it has that mayo has that little
bit of tang so it counter balances like
the beans and the meat and no one even
knows where it comes from and then you
put the chicken you [ __ ] [ __ ]
how are you revealing all that we need
to cut that [ __ ] out
how are you revealing all this [ __ ] nah
there's a lot of other stuff that she
explained to me like uh when she makes
her mexican rice
she's not stingy she's that's what's
dope about her she's not a [ __ ]
gatekeeper too so when she like figures
[ __ ] out she says it's a secret but if
literally anyone can ask her like what
is that she'll tell you she'll tell you
everything yeah when she makes her
mexican rice uh there's this like uh
like lemon or lime cilantro rice thing
that she makes
and then uh when she first opened it i
was like
what is that
and she had uh strips of jalapenos
yeah uh on top it's not jalapenos it's
the actual pepper it's the
it's the california one that you like oh
okay or anaheim anaheim yeah she has
strips of those
she takes them off and throws them in
the trash and then i was like what what
was that what was that all about she
goes well this is my like lemon or lime
cilantro rice she goes but when you
steam it with these things on there this
this there's like it gives it like this
extra body that goes into the rice so
when you're eating the rice it has like
this very aromatic feel but since they
don't see it they don't know where it's
coming from so she goes every time i
steam it i put a couple of these strips
in there and i just take them i just
throw them away because it doesn't
actually taste good with the rice you
just want that like extra body in the
how does how do you know that how do you
know that
yeah because i don't know if my grandma
was much of a cook which is interesting
her mom hmm yeah so like like i i for
the longest and i keep saying this [ __ ]
i'm just always so busy but like for the
longest i've always been like i need to
watch you cook and i'm like how much of
that she goes i don't know i eyeball it
and i'm like [ __ ] so i don't really even
know how to put like the recipes
together but i definitely need to get
her recipes my mom sucks at cooking but
she tries hard one time she made like
this plate of uh like vegetables and it
was like it was actually really juicy so
the the the cooking technique was good
um but then the seasoning is always off
right and then this time she made like
this plate of vegetables i was like
damn this vegetables are really good
what did you do
and then she goes i took the seasoning
pack from instant noodle and i just put
it on the vegetable oh my no [ __ ]
wonder why it's so good because it's not
even her seasoning it's already a
pre-made pack yeah so i can tell that
she tries
but i think she's that first college
educated uh yeah so generation
like mother what is it called like
housekeeping yeah so yeah
yeah so that kind of like domesticated
education wasn't prioritizing their
family yeah so my mom actually sucks at
cooking but i think she tries to be good
yeah same
um and i had my grandma living with us
who's also a [ __ ] wait did i just say
my mom wasn't that no your grandma sucks
no my grandma's actually really good at
cooking
why did you just go on a rant for five
minutes [ __ ] roasting the [ __ ] out of
your grandma to a christmas i know she
passed away i'm sorry and now she is
like yeah yes
yes she is in heaven for sure she's a
[ __ ] wonderful woman too [ __ ] did you
ever say that because i'm so stupid uh
she was an angel she was an angel she is
an ancient and you talk so much [ __ ]
about it i did i know i'm going to hell
you're so right um but yeah she was a
killer cook too what am i talking about
i can't believe i just said that [ __ ]
hey no
vitamins i know i'm [ __ ] losing it
i'm getting old
but she was [ __ ] banger too man she
would make this thing called arroz con
leche which is like a staple mexican
it's kind of like um milk
it is
yeah is it like tres leches no not even
clothes is like a pudding
so it's like it's like white rice but
not like asian white rice but it is a
white rice with cinnamon right with
cinnamon sticks um with milk sugar uh
so it tastes kind of like horchata yeah
i've had it it's delicious but the way
she made it maybe because it's my
grandma was just so bummed she could
even make eggs and i'm like god damn
these eggs are bomb and it's just
[ __ ] eggs
um maybe it's eggs
maybe she would do this thing where she
would like
she would like taste it
and i should stick her finger in it
again i'm like oh grandma you're [ __ ]
double dipping but i'm like that's how
you do it though but she was so clean as
a woman like as a lady she was very
ladylike like every morning she would
wake up before the house was up she
would put her hair in curlers get her
hair done until she was like 90. okay
well she looked like late 80s but um
till the very end her hair was always
dyed her nail polish was always on never
change you never smelled her underwear
um i she would hand wash her underwear
and there were never stains on it okay
then she's clean she's very clean she
would always wear perfume she would wear
wings
if you have what's wings that's the name
of the perfume oh i've never even heard
of it yeah it's a whoo it's a grandma
it's a thick
[ __ ] because i think when you're
older you're sensitive yeah yes i think
that's the one she could smell and it
was like
but she always smelled good and her
nails were always done she had long
nails and they were always like
she would always file them and like she
had her little jewelry on she has had
earrings uh she had permanent makeup on
because like she's mexican no but she
got her eyebrows done not like a chola
take it easy her eyeliner was done think
more korean uh like her lip liner was
done think like a neutral like a pink
like a nice rosy and then she would just
put lips out so she was always always
done up always
um
so like any time she did anything she
never grossed me out she was such a
clean lady yeah so she could double dip
as much as she wanted and i was like
that's cool i want to go back to talking
about how
how the [ __ ] are you going to build a
community
i don't i don't i don't it's so hard for
me to see that in you because i know how
much you hate people fine you know how
it's going to happen it's going to
happen through taika and all the [ __ ]
that we put him in like how so you're
actually going to try to make friends
with taika's friends parents
if they're cool yeah
okay let's say another more cool because
that's because building a community has
nothing to do with whether they're cool
or not because you're not trying to
connect
finances you're trying to connect for
the sake of the community
uh
like uh our neighbors because you gotta
force the connection i'll start with our
neighbors
okay so like let's say they go hey one
come on over for a labor day barbecue
let's do it you're actually gonna start
saying yes to people yeah i have to
that's [ __ ] crazy i know i mean this
is all theory right now where are you
becoming
okay they go hey it's halloween um
uh i think it might be a good idea for
maybe our kids to go trick-or-treat and
then we'll just set up a little grill in
the front yeah i mean you're gonna have
to hear me vent a little bit and i'm
gonna like have a little mini panic
attack but then after that i'm gonna be
like
hey
and then after i'm done with them and be
like man that was cool or whatever and
then i'm just gonna like
want to chill for a couple weeks what is
it a couple weeks fine what is it about
connecting with people
that
you hate so much okay so hate is a
strong word and it's not that i hate it
it's just a lot of internal work for me
okay so like for me i live in my head a
lot right and i like to just stay zen i
like to just kind of relax because i
already have my own [ __ ]
turmoil in my brain all the goddamn time
i'm always looking for a bunch of
different problems and i'm constantly
solving a bunch of different problems
and i'm looking at what you're doing and
i'm thinking three steps ahead and if
i'm hosting people i'm thinking about
like okay what is it going to look like
that's why i'm such a great producer in
such a great place but let's say you're
not hosting [ __ ] it doesn't matter ask
you to come over it doesn't matter
i'm still looking at that because now
i'm thinking as as a person that's
invited how can i contribute to this
this whole thing right so whether that's
me contributing in a conversation or me
contributing in the energy of the room
like how can i make this energy of the
space feel dope so i'm contributing that
or i'm like hey i noticed that the
hostess or the host or whatever is like
doing a bunch of [ __ ] hey how can i help
or i'm not even going to ask how can i
help i'm already helping so i'm like
giving a lot of myself out there you
know for the sake of it
and it's very draining so i don't hate
it it's just at the end of it all i'm
like holy [ __ ] i gave so much of myself
and it's not something that i'm like
forced to do it's just in my nature to
do it
um so just i get so
[ __ ]
drained and you feel that way even with
your mom and your family your brother
like when you go over to their house
does it feel like that too
um
with my family
like after you see your brother or
something or your brother's family you
feel like you got to like just go crawl
in a hole for two weeks well i've been
working on it a lot
um and because i see them more
frequently i feel like okay cool i
understand their dynamic
and i'm gonna respect their space so
then i can back off
but i still feel tired
with my mom it's different because now
we're like best friends that's candy you
know so like she's just like me or maybe
vice versa i'm just like her yeah that
we both live with high anxiety and we're
both thinking of the exact same things
all the time that we both look at each
other no communication and we're just
like we're just not doing [ __ ] and it's
perfect because what if you find people
like that
in the community i mean that's a needle
and a haystack like of course that's
that would be amazing right but like not
everyone's like that it's rare and you
have to go through a lot of things in
order to see that so i did find uh
so through one of my girlfriends one of
her girlfriends we connected really
really well because we're the exact same
way so as soon as i so whenever there's
like a new group dynamic i try to just
take a step back so that i can see what
this dynamic is about and see if i'm
even needed for any of it right because
i'm i don't know again that's probably
for my mom where i'm always trying to
like help in any way that i can or like
make things smooth or efficient or
whatever the [ __ ] but then i would see
her do that and she took that role in
and i was like i know exactly who you
are dude so we connected pretty hard
because of stuff like that i see but
it's rare because i really really like
community
and especially like the um
the neighbors style of community what i
really like about that is
growing up i think that's one cool thing
that i really liked about my street is
everyone was really different but
everyone really accepted
and also kind of embraced it
you know so like it wasn't like everyone
was of the same like
socioeconomic
like level like there was a guy that was
like i think he was 15 and i think the
parents are both in jail so he's raising
his two sisters and i don't know if the
government even knew about it but he was
the older one and he had two sisters and
uh how could they not know about it if
they're in jail that doesn't make any
sense i don't know but there was zero
adult presents ever
it was just one 15 year old dude and
like two like i don't know like six and
eight or something like that and he was
raising them and then we had uh
the baller of the street he's like the
only two-story house in the entire
street and everyone knew he was rich
then i had my filipino neighbors and
then everyone like kind of just all hung
out and kind of just embraced like what
everyone had and we knew okay that guy
had the basketball court so we'll all go
to his house to play basketball and it
was just like this very it just felt
warm and comfortable and everything was
okay we didn't all have to be similar
one of my other best friends was like uh
super indian like extremely traditional
like you got like the grandma's girl's
backyard it's a [ __ ] herb farm oh
sick yeah and then uh the dad they just
wear the regular i think it's called
asari okay yeah so she the mom were
sorry grandma was sorry um the the dad
had a i'm not sure if it's a turban or a
head wrap uh probably a turban and so it
was like very very traditional no one
spoke english except for your friend my
friend and his sister
and uh everyone was just accepting how
cool yeah like and then it was
multicultural like the kids maybe like
everyone was just newly immigrated there
and they're all like okay well this is
our community like
we trust
yeah yeah and the the kid that was 15 is
mexican and then the filipino guy he was
the one that taught me how to like
that's how crazy how multicultural your
street was yeah my my filipino neighbor
uh
they taught me how to wax cars because
they were like really into like hobbies
philippines were always into hobbies
they taught me how to like wax a car at
an early age because i would see a car
and then he would like go like this he
goes it has to be cloudy before it could
be shiny do you think we can still get
that now though because i feel like
everyone is
any free time that anyone has anymore
they're just on their phone inside their
house that's the problem i think that's
one big kryptonite to that
but i do think people still do crave
connection
and so i think like um
it's it'll take a lot of encouragement
if people like kind of putting that
offer out first you know like hey i'm
going to have a pool party do you want
to come
and it takes people going oh sure i'll
bring this and then you're like wait you
know how to make that you see that's so
cute to me yeah like as you're saying it
i'm like oh i would love that like i
would love to be that house
and then you can get one out it's the
day of and i'm going [ __ ] that [ __ ]
why am i like that i don't know i mean
i'm introverted too so i i really feel
you but i'm not as introverted as you
are you don't seem intro i mean you do
seem introverted but when it comes to
like one-on-one interactions you're
actually really good whereas for me i'm
like oh that's the worst for me
i think i really like connecting with
people on common interests
that part is like like you know our
neighbor across the street um when we're
talking about getting our backyards done
he goes oh dude you gotta come see my
backyard he goes
my cooking section is insane i'm like
cooking really so this is when we first
moved in not even for like a week and
i'm like sure and then uh he got his
whole entire backyard done by like the
landscaper of the town you know everyone
talks about them like they're like the
mercedes of it so i had to go see it
so it did feel kind of weird because i'm
like [ __ ] i don't even know you and i'm
just going through your house but i'm
like i guess we're neighbors so i should
be fine so i do have that anxiety a
little bit and i walked in his backyard
and man he has a
uh he has a chili like vap maker thing
where like you know usually the
countertop is like this
it's like straight but then his counter
goes like this and then it dips down
because there's like a stove because
it's made to put a big vat right there
and then the water that comes up on top
is boiling hot water so he's from
louisiana
so that is to as soon as he turns it
boiling hot water for chili or crawfish
boils or whatever so it's made for that
that's how often he does that you know
and i'm like that is sick i've never had
his chili i mean either but he would
like he would just show me all these
things and i really like connecting like
that and i told him i like to grill so
we're already like that much closer they
go oh you're a griller and i'm a chili
and like a a crawfish type guy and we're
just talking about stuff so like you
kind of so that is the part that i like
because um when you connect with someone
in common interest like let's say in a
further group setting when we all go
hang out or something when you look at
them there's a glimmer in each other's
eyes you're like we're the cooking
people you know with the cooking people
yeah like that yeah kind of like when
like two vets get together you know like
if i know someone else is a marine and
we're in like an area like
one of the marines in here so i like
that like feeling like you just feel
like a sense of like belonging or even
if i'm like at the airport right i go
there and i see someone's biceps i'm
like we both like to lift don't we
and then that guy is looking around he's
like [ __ ] man not a single lifter lifter
i hear especially that asian guy that
keeps winking at me like that okay
really weird
buggering his lips
what does he want
yeah i don't know i i want it that's
what i want right
uh we'll see how that goes but
so the vessel in which i'm going to try
to get that to happen is one
obviously through
our community uh through our neighbors
it's a physical neighborhood yes yeah
um
and then the other one would be through
taika and then the last one would
probably be through like once we free up
a little bit more and doing jiu jitsu
and stuff like that oh like we actually
like we put ourselves out there and
connect with those people yeah yeah
that's the only way i see it happening
yeah
because i love it like my sister's house
was that and i loved how that felt like
my sister's very much open door policy
um was she cool with all her neighbors
too
uh i was too young to really know notice
but there was always people in her house
she was never alone
she always had friends over or cousin
like uh her
ex-husband's now all cousins um there
was always people there like it was
always a good time like every weekend
was always like a barbecue or something
was happening there was some sort of
party or get-together and not party like
in the sense where like there's a
[ __ ] dj but like just a gathering of
some sort every [ __ ] weekend and i'm
like man this is tight i like that my
sister my sister-in-law has that too
where like um before everyone started
having kids and getting married and
stuff like her sisters were always over
cousins like that house was always so
robust
um and full of just like noise and and
laughter and like food and whatever
that's candy yeah and i love it
i don't know how much i love it for i'm
a [ __ ] mess man i know you are a mess
you're a [ __ ] because like i want it
but then i also don't want it what about
that one time when all the friends came
over like david
um that was cool
jeremy and like when they all came over
and we had that little weekend did you
like that or was that yeah was that
still like high anxiety that was super
rad i loved it
um
no i thought it was super rad
but like for a long term probably not
but you said you liked the weekly theme
so let's say everyone moved and moved to
vegas would you want the weekly thing
yeah if we go to different people's
houses yeah i think that would be fun oh
so you wouldn't want to host it all the
time but you still want to be together
yeah oh okay yeah yeah i think that'd be
fun
i see yeah yeah i like that weekly theme
too i think that's cool
just have to build that out here
especially too with taika um
you know we've been doing this baby
number two thing very casually um but in
the meantime so what's the casual
version of it
like where i'm not like taking tests to
see if i'm like
um what's it called like fertile or like
i'm not doing any of that like yeah yeah
we're not stressing over it at all we're
just putting it in the right hole this
time
what do you mean
wait a minute i thought that was crystal
clear
what do you mean you were you were
putting in the wrong hole before well i
was putting whatever hole you wanted but
i'm putting it where i want it
you're [ __ ] crazy
um
yeah so but in the meantime i do like
when that's why like this whole month of
og or like the whole month of august
when taika was was it august july sorry
the whole month of july when title was
already on summer break um
i'm like well there's no reason to stay
in vegas
because all family and everything is out
there our businesses are out there so
i'm like [ __ ] it i'm just gonna live
with my mom for that whole month and
that whole month he was just playing
with his cousins and like we'd go over
to my brother's house and it was really
cool because every day there's something
to do i love seeing them together oh man
but they fight so much i was like what
is happening
but yeah so we'll see how that goes i'll
keep you posted i'll let you know but
just know that there's gonna be a lot of
venting
from building the community aspect of
stuff yeah but give me some time i need
to adjust to it once tyco starts school
which is dude next in a couple days oh
my god i'm gonna start looking i've
actually never been a part of this uh
officially but i've participated in the
sidelines of it but that's one of the
reasons why i love church
because like um so i used to play
um
drums for a praise band
and so i would show up on fridays and on
sundays it's more formal so it's like uh
it's less than that but friday nights
it's like more like it's fun when you
get to seeing and then
and what was cool is like churches they
always got activities you know they're
gonna like whether it's a small activity
for the night where they play a game or
they play mafia or whatever or their the
next weekend they're gonna go and go
camping or the whole or like four or
five families are gonna go do whatever
and my mom's work
um
it was kind of like that which is cool
so her and her best friend and like two
or three other friends they were all
like taiwanese american and so like i
think that was the main reason why we
even moved to cerritos because like my
we used to live in gardena and then when
my mom wanted to move to another city
she would talk to her co-workers and
everyone's like oh come to cerritos we
all live over here oh cool so that's the
whole reason like the school district is
good whatever that's awesome yeah so we
ended up uh going there and then so
all of the parents would put all the
kids in the same things
so like we would all go okay oh yeah we
there's chinese school we should put
them in chinese school on saturday so we
all went to the same chinese school and
they're like oh yeah there's this new
kung fu place in like buena park you
should go check it out so all of us
would try that so all of the kids
uh would generally kind of like migrate
slowly into each other area because like
one parent really liked it and that was
really really cool like i was never like
um
like the tightest of friends with my
mom's friends kids
but there was
that level of comfort yeah that was
really cool because if like let's say
there was a no school day or whatever it
was so cool for my mom to just be able
to drop me off at a friend's house like
if one of the moms to stay at home yeah
that is cool and i just feel i just feel
comfortable yeah you know and then my
mom and that mom like goes and carpools
to work and then the dad stays home or
whatever and so it just felt like a
almost extended family so in terms of
that type of community
like i really really love
damn that does sound really tight okay
i'll work on it i'll work on it okay
yeah it's
it's really cuny like uh i remember um
uh when we went have you ever met my
mom's buddy teresa auntie teresa you
have so like
our family her family this is the first
time we went to the bay together went to
the monterey bay and you know how
there's tide pools there
so like us being in a van
together like two three families in a
big old van going up there collecting
little hermit crabs like have fun like
these things and have pictures with them
with these kids so it wasn't like we
were like got super tight later on uh
maybe because i was just a troublemaker
so i kind of went on my own path i'm
sure that's what happened but um
to have to have been able to share those
experiences with other kids and other
families is freaking cool yeah i bet i
bet yes i know i got it i gotta do it
and if anything if i'm not gonna do it
for myself then for sure it's gonna
happen because i want that for tycha so
yeah we'll get there we'll get there so
just give me some time um you're like
[ __ ] how much time you need you've been
[ __ ] forever yeah it's been like [ __ ]
15 years ago
i know we're working towards that damn
[ __ ] [ __ ] but as soon as typically
[ __ ]
but as soon as tyke is in school yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna pay more attention
to that
and just like go this is for taika this
verteca is for daika and then we'll take
it from there yeah no i i just i i'll
use taika as like the driving force for
that because um
i do
just having my mom here and seeing how
people do different or do things
differently you know with their wisdom
and just whatever they've done i'm like
[ __ ] that is so sick like i was saying
like watching my sister-in-law raise
kids too and i'm like oh is that or like
i would call her up hey this is
happening what do i do you know um and
it's been so helpful watching her do her
thing because i'm like okay got it
that's what to do oh [ __ ] that's what i
shouldn't do that's you know so it's
been really cool yeah i i even liked it
when john and malia came
because um it's cool to also be the
pastor longer of the information true
you know like when like when we like i
like your sister-in-law because she has
two older kids right so for them like
the next two set of kids that are
taika's age it's like bam just rinse and
repeat so easy so we're like absorbing
all this information and now we got a
whole wealth of information we don't
even know until we see another new
parent and we see them struggling with
something like oh yeah just do this
disney like oh wow so i actually love
seeing like a whole range of kids
because they also take care of each
other and i never thought i would see
the big brother side of taika and he's
so
[ __ ] cute as a big brother and so
like um that actually makes me like i
actually like daydream a lot about what
taika would be like as an older brother
i just think it's gonna be so cuny yeah
yeah he was really soft because i
thought he was gonna be that kid that
doesn't understand babies yeah and was
just gonna like throw [ __ ] at them or
just kind of be rough
um but he was so gentle and his cousins
are like that too did you see how like
when my sister-in-law's sister shows up
with her little daughter who's like
maybe a year old yeah she's barely
wobbly yeah she's all walking and [ __ ]
and then all the boys are like treating
her like a little princess they're like
oh you little cutie or like here you go
or like they like they're just so
gentle with her yeah i know we we're
we're working on the baby number two
we're definitely working
we're working on baby number two i'm
saying yeah i even like uh
seeing when tyka um goes and hangs out
with his older cousin that's a girl and
you kind of see like
the big sister
activate in her yeah and i was like whoa
that's another cool side so it's just i
think that's the community part that i
like yeah you don't know
you don't know like what activates what
and people yeah and then just seeing the
other
dad becoming a grandpa like seeing that
side of him where you're like who the
[ __ ] is this man he hugs my tiger every
day and it's so cute like every night
before i go to sleep i make him go hug
grandpa and you just see like my dad hug
him and that's literally like the
happiest 30 seconds of his day
he's so happy that's so sad
and tech is going like oh
grandpa and i know the way my dad smells
and i'm just like you just gotta go hug
him
cause i remember um i think old dudes
they just smell like [ __ ] because um i
would uh go to taiwan and visit my
grandpa right and then one of my
favorite things in the world is you know
those little scooters so i would stand
scooters like the actual like mo like
mopeds yeah like uh like best buds right
so my my my grandpa actually had like a
vespa from that era like 60s or 70s and
he just took really good care of it it's
all around and she looks dope and one of
my favorite things is my grandpa would
go around town running errands and he'll
take me with him and i'm standing in
front and i hold on to the handlebars
too and it feels like i'm driving but
he's the one driving how fun yeah we
would like go in and out of like weaving
and out of traffic and do all that stuff
and because it's super normal
but
every time i had to go
my grandpa would bring his other helmet
and because he got that old man stench
grease like he would give it to me and i
would just like always stare at it
i couldn't smell like [ __ ] [ __ ]
but i would have to hold my breath and
put it on my head and i'm just like
and it's humid in taiwan so i could feel
that i could feel i could smell the
stench going down and the wind blowing
but and i know that's what i had to do
to be safe or whatever but so me knowing
how my grandpa smells i just know how
this grandpa smells and so i'm sure
taika every time he goes to hug my dad
he's like oh
my [ __ ] taika is a [ __ ] butt head
and he takes his he for sure gets this
from you he'll walk by my mom and she's
taller right yeah like she's taller than
average and um his head is right where
her butt would be
so then he'll be like oh grandma you
smell like butt or whatever right she's
like what she'll smell me smell me no i
don't and then she he'll smell he goes
okay no you smell you smell good but
she's he's like oh grandma you smell
like butt and i'm like god damn it ty
you're gonna get in so much [ __ ]
trouble at school man
but yes
i need that community i really do i miss
it
yeah more than ever too especially
social media stuff
i think uh
everyone is craving for that human
connection and so i think it's just
going to be good
all right fine i'll start putting out
flyers hey wanna guy you guys want to
come over
and i don't know just [ __ ] awkwardly
sit down and you're gonna put out paper
flyers no i'm just [ __ ] around old
school style i'm just [ __ ] around hey
party at my house
yeah yeah yeah we just got to build out
our backyard get all that wrapped up so
we can start like
um i don't know yeah that's what that's
like that's like my number one priority
i want to get the house
cuny because i know when there's a cuny
house i remember at glendale house it
just feels so good you know when people
come over just feels like an awesome
time we had our swing and [ __ ] yeah our
pool table
yeah
yeah we'll get it there we'll get it
there give me some time all right on
that note
do you have anything else you want to
add no
you sure about that
you can't check me out too fast
all right well thank you so much for
listening and i will catch you
next
week